[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen de las noticias
más destacadas relacionadas con la
pandemia del cob y 19 a continuación les
presento los temas más destacados del
programa de hoy
hace un año fue declarada por la
organización mundial de la salud la
pandemia de kobe 19 desde entonces más
de 118 millones de personas han padecido
el coronavirus y 2.6 millones de
personas han fallecido en esta emisión
hacemos un balance de lo que nos deja
este año de emergencia sanitaria global
que continúa y a la que seguimos
haciéndole frente tenemos también en
detalle el plan de rescate aprobado por
el presidente de eeuu joe biden para
hacer frente a la crisis desatada por la
pandemia se trata de 1.9 millones de
dólares destinados a ayudas directas y
estímulos económicos y también estímulos
económicos para agilizar el proceso de
la vacunación en varios condados y en
estados de ese país tenemos todos los
detalles y vamos a ir finalmente a
paraguay en donde la dirección general
de vigilancia de la salud advirtió que
este país está en alerta roja sanitaria
debido al aumento sostenido de contagios
y al récord de casos de kobe 19 a esto
se suma también el malestar ciudadano
que ha llevado a miles de paraguayos a
las calles en rechazo a la gestión de la
pandemia por parte del
el precario sistema de salud y piden la
renuncia del presidente mario abdo
benítez pues comenzamos el programa y ya
lo decíamos se cumple un año desde que
la organización mundial de la salud la
oms declaró la pandemia de kobe 19 le
repito la cifra 118 millones de personas
ya han sido diagnosticadas con el
coronavirus y 2.6 millones de personas
han fallecido un año después estamos
avanzando con muchos altibajos en la
vacunación a nivel mundial un proceso
que ha demostrado ser desigual muy
complejo y sumamente lento muy lento
para lo que nos gustaría así ha sido
este primer año de pandemia de kobe 19
veamos
era el 11 de marzo de 2020 así estaban
las principales calles de roma a la
capital de italia o las del epicentro
del cob y 19 en wuhan china los
supermercados no daban abasto y la
población temía que se acabase en las
existencias de papel higiénico no había
mascarillas que se reservaban para el
personal de salud
erigidos en héroes involuntarios las
escuelas cerraban y las bolsas se
desplomaban el virus llegaba a américa
latina' ese dia panamá y bolivia
declararon sus primeros casos los eeuu
prohibía viajes con europa y la
población mundial quedaba aislada en su
territorio y muchas personas en su
propia casa ese 11 de marzo la
organización mundial de la salud
declaraba la pandemia mundial
estamos profundamente preocupados tanto
por los alarmantes niveles de
propagación y gravedad como por los
alarmantes niveles de inacción leve
o fin action
we are there for me por lo tanto hemos
evaluado que el commit 19 se puede
caracterizar como una pandemia
caracteres y pandémica países de todo el
mundo ordenaban restricciones para dos
semanas las más largas de nuestras vidas
un año después el virus sigue activo con
alrededor de 118 millones de casos y más
de 2 millones y medio de fallecidos
primero fue china luego italia-españa
nueva york' y brasil el kobe 19 saturaba
hospitales de todo el mundo para después
reaparecer con fuerza en virulentas
nuevas olas y variantes los efectos del
coronavirus han llevado a las economías
a la peor crisis en décadas esto ha
derivado en protestas corrupción pobreza
y también en el surgimiento de un
negacionismo que ha grabado el curso de
la pandemia sin embargo también han
surgido olas de solidaridad que culminan
en una cooperación mundial histórica con
la que se ha conseguido desarrollar
vacunas en tiempo récord una señal de
esperanza para que el fin de la pandemia
cada día más cerca en un año imposible
de olvidar
vamos a conversar y a profundizar sobre
este tema hemos invitado al programa
francisco becerra él es ex subdirector
de la organización panamericana de la
salud la opc y con él haremos un balance
de este primer año de pandemia de kobe
19 señor becerra allí en la ciudad de
mexico muchas gracias por acompañarnos
hoy en el programa y cuál es el balance
que usted hace de este año de pandemia
de kobe 19 más emergencia a nivel
internacional a nivel global
gracias entregó muy amable por la
invitación en realidad ha sido un año
muy muy pesado para todo el mundo y
hemos visto o sea ya decía las cifras
generales de lo que ha pasado en esta en
esta pandemia sin embargo si nos
centramos en la parte latinoamericana
creo que hay muchas experiencias y
muchas lecciones aprendidas que aún
ahora nos siguen costando entenderlas y
tenemos dentro de algunos países de la
región tenemos una gran cantidad de
mortalidad y tenemos simplemente entre
los 15 primeros países de mortalidad en
números en total de números tenemos 6
países que son de la región de las
américas y de ellos 5 son
latinoamericanos brasil méxico colombia
argentina y perú ahora si nos vamos a
muertes por millón de habitantes méxico
es el de más alto número con 1514 perú
con mil 486 brazil 1.293 colombia 1280 y
argentina- mil 190 por cada millón de
habitantes esto nos habla de problemas
en varios frentes
de ellos es principalmente la parte de
lo que concierne a la fragilidad de los
sistemas de salud y que no pudieron
hacer frente a muchas de las situaciones
que se enfrentaron con una gran demanda
de casos de terapia intensiva la no
disposición de camas de ventiladores que
obligaron a los países a comprar y salir
a demandar esos servicios posteriormente
tenemos el problema de que no estuvieron
preparados y no se prepararon habiendo
visto lo que pasaba en italia lo que
había pasado en asia y no pudimos tener
la preparación necesaria y otra que jugó
un papel muy importante la parte
política sobre la parte científica usted
sacaba la imagen del ex presidente de
trump pero veamos como en eeuu en brasil
y méxico que son los tres países número
uno dos y tres en cantidad de muertes a
nivel global
no ha habido una política directa de
apoyo presidencial
a toda esta situación de la pandemia en
esos países ya esto añadimos ahora los
problemas de accesibilidad a la vacuna
si bien por un lado tenemos
y que en menos de un año teníamos ya
vacuna disponible gracias a las
plataformas de vacunas que ya utilizamos
a nivel global por desgracia los
problemas de registro los problemas de
producción los problemas de distribución
y los problemas de acceso a la vacuna
están creando unas inequidades muy
importantes en materia de vacunación en
toda la región y principalmente en
países latinoamericanos y africanos y
vamos a ver también inequidades al
interior de los países mismos señor
becerra ese es el balance que usted hace
a nivel social y como en términos
generales pero a nivel médico y a nivel
científico que enseña este año sobre
todo para la región de américa latina
que usted ya decía dejó sobre la mesa y
dejó en evidencia esa fragilidad de los
sistemas de salud de los países de
américa latina
yo creo que uno la velocidad en que
muchos ministerios de salud y
autoridades sanitarias pudieron
adecuarse a la pandemia y hacer frente
hay muchos países que han tenido un
mejor control y mejor atención médica 2
creo que también la importancia de
internacionalmente compartir los
protocolos de atención debemos de
reconocer y entender que el enfermedad
de kobe 19 no hay un medicamento
específico para atender la enfermedad se
trata de un síndrome con mucha
sintomatología que requiere
definitivamente un manejo muy
especializado y el el gran bagaje que
dejó el manejo global ha permitido tener
ya protocolos de atención médica mucho
mejores que están permitiendo que haya
menos pacientes que ingresan a terapia
intensiva que puedan depender de
ventilador y que haya fallecimientos sin
embargo tenemos también grandes fallas
en cuestión epidemiológica de
trazabilidad de contactos de prevención
también hay una base que nos corresponde
con nosotros como ciudadanía entender
que tenemos que poner de nuestra parte
el uso de cubrebocas del lavado de manos
en no tener reuniones etcétera que por
desgracia hemos visto que en muchos
países eso no ha sucedido así porque
pese a que esté avanzando la vacunación
la emergencia sigue y sigue habiendo
contagios y sigue habiendo muertes
incluso algunas regiones como lo veíamos
en italia en chile en brasil van a
regresar a confinamiento en los próximos
días por la gran cantidad de casos que
sigue entonces para el mundo que sigue
para la sociedad que sigue para el
planeta haciéndole frente al kobe 19
pues primero continuar con las medidas
preventivas que es lo que en realidad va
a funcionar con vacuna o sin vacuna en
ese momento hasta que no haya grandes
cantidades de población vacunada para
obtener una una verdadera cobertura de
epidemiológica de inmunidad por grupo no
vamos a poder contener el virus de
transmisión de persona a persona aún así
aunque tuviéramos el 100 por ciento de
la población mundial vacunada con las
variantes que hay no sabemos si las
vacunas que existen actualmente van a
poder frenar el contagio de nuevas
variantes que están que están saliendo
recordemos que hay más de 4000 variantes
de los virus
algunas son con mutaciones pequeñas que
no pasa nada pero otras son mutaciones
más importantes como los de gran bretaña
la brasileña la sudafricana que pueden
tener un impacto todavía peor a futuro
y creo que aquí se es y si no hay una
verdadera acceso a las vacunas a nivel
global y solamente se logra contener el
perdón para que la vacuna llegue a los
países más grandes en cuanto a rica y a
población y que tienen la posibilidad de
comprar vacunas que hay países que
tienen tres veces o cuatro veces más de
la vacuna que requieren para su
población países más pobres no van a
poder la comer a su población y eso pone
sigue poniendo al mundo entero y eso ya
lo estamos evidenciando con algunas
naciones en áfrica en el sudeste
asiático señor becerra la emergencia
requirió que fueran desarrolladas las
vacunas en tiempo récord incluso usando
nueva tecnología y nuevos dispositivos
para poderla desarrollar estos nuevos
protocolos de desarrollo de vacunas
pueden ser entonces aplicados para
desarrollar vacunas para otras
enfermedades o para posibles pandemias y
epidemias que puedan venir en el futuro
como lo ve usted totalmente creo que
debemos recordar que también la base de
la vacuna para de dna como la de
fallecer y la de moderna ya sea están
utilizando para la vacuna del ébola en
áfrica desgraciadamente como el ébola
eran pequeños
brotes epidemiológicos que no había una
gran población afectada no se había
promovido el uso de la
y nos habéis experimentado más con la
vacuna sin embargo en el último brote
epidémico de áfrica que fue muy
importante en cuanto de volar ahí se
empezó a utilizar la vacuna con base de
rn a esto permitió que esa base de la
vacuna se pudiera ya utilizar ahora para
una de kobe
y obviamente otras vacunas que existen
ahora para cubir tienen una base de ya
de otras vacunas que se utilizan
normalmente en el espectro de las
inmunizaciones globales entonces si
estos avances en materia de innovación
tecnológica pueden favorecer un
desarrollo mucho más rápido de vacunas
santiago cuando no hay cuando no hay
tratamiento específico una vacuna que
esté en fase de experimentación
genéticamente para mí es la mejor
solución cuando no hay un tratamiento
específico nos quedamos con esa frase
señor francisco becerra ex subdirector
de la organización panamericana de la
salud gracias por estar con nosotros
aquí en france 24
avanzamos con otros temas en eeuu el
presidente yo byd en aprobó un plan de
rescate de 1.9 billones de dólares que
serán destinados a ayudas directas para
levantar la economía y para que las
autoridades locales puedan agilizar la
vacunación a nivel regional se trata del
tercer plan de rescate en este país
desde que comenzó la pandemia del cobi
19 el mandatario también anunció que a
partir del primero de mayo todos los
adultos serán elegibles para vacunarse
lo que permitiría recuperar un poco la
normalidad en ese país veamos
y ya es una realidad el presidente
demócrata joe biden convirtió en ley el
plan de rescate para paliar la crisis
económica dejada por la pandemia 19
billones de dólares en ayudas y
estímulos
era una de las puntas de lanza de la
campaña de bailén durante las elecciones
una promesa cumplida menos de dos meses
después de su llegada a la casa blanca
la ley incluye pagos directos de 1400
dólares a los estadounidenses que
ingresen menos de 75 mil dólares anuales
una suma mayor a la de los planes
anteriores firmados por trump también
dará ayudas semanales de 300 dólares a
las personas sin empleo hasta el fin del
verano y otorgará ayudas millonarias a
gobiernos locales además de prever
partidas para reabrir las escuelas
impulsar el plan de vacunación y
aumentar las pruebas de kobe 19 además
biden cumplió otra promesa y dije que
quería inyectar 100 millones de dosis
durante mis primeros 100 días de
gobierno esta noche puedo decir que no
sólo alcanzaremos ese objetivo sino que
lo superaremos porque estamos en camino
de lograr las 100 millones de dosis en
mis primeros 60 días sixtina
esta noche anuncio que dirijo todos los
estados y territorios para que todos los
adultos mayores de 18 años sean
elegibles para vacunarse el primero de
mayo leyes de miwa el objetivo del
demócrata que se apunta a otra victoria
durante sus primeros meses en la casa
blanca es que los estadounidenses puedan
celebrar el 4 de julio día de la
independencia con una cierta normalidad
en sus propias palabras que eeuu se
independice del virus
esta semana paraguay protagonizó varios
titulares en los medios de comunicación
internacionales por el anuncio de la
dirección general de vigilancia de la
salud que advirtió que este país estaba
en alerta roja sanitaria por el rápido
aumento de los casos de kobe 19 y la
cifra récords que comenzó a presentar
por varios meses paraguay logró mantener
digamos que relativamente a raya el
coronavirus y presentó muy pocos casos
pero ahora tiene más de 175.000 casos y
los fallecidos ya superan los 3400 el
sistema hospitalario está al borde del
colapso y también hay un gran malestar
ciudadano que ha llevado a los
paraguayos a las calles para pedir la
renuncia del presidente mario abdo
benítez vamos a contactar con fernando
box ya él es el corresponsal de france
24 en la ciudad de asunción hola
fernando gracias por acompañarnos hoy en
el programa y cuál es la situación
entonces que se está presentando allí en
paraguay después de declarar esta alerta
roja
paraguay empezó como una historia de
éxito frente a países vecinos que
rápidamente fueron avasallados por el
coronavirus hoy la situación es otra la
situación sanitaria en paraguay está en
su peor momento desde el inicio de la
pandemia con pico de contagios y pico de
muertes diarias por el coronavirus esta
semana el ministerio de salud pública
declaró una alerta roja sanitaria debido
al aumento acelerado de contagios esto
llevó a algunos médicos a hablar de una
segunda ola de contagios y el propio
ministerio de salud ya sospecha que la
variante del cobi 19 de manaus que es
más infecciosa ya circula en nuestro
país a la fecha son más de 175.000 los
casos confirmados de coronavirus y unas
3.400 muertes por esta enfermedad
la situación sanitaria está bastante mal
debido a que hay una escasez de
medicamentos y una falta de camas de
terapia y esto llevó incluso la semana
pasada al ministro de salud julio más a
renunciar al canal al cargo y ocasionar
una crisis política para este gobierno
fernando la crisis sanitaria y también
la rabia de los paraguayos nos ha
llevado a las calles veíamos las
imágenes de muchos ciudadanos allí en el
centro de asunción manifestándose sin
importar la emergencia qué es lo que
están reclamando ellos exactamente
hace una semana miles de manifestantes
salen a las calles en asunción en otros
puntos del país para protestar contra
este gobierno y sobre todo el reclamo se
centra en el manejo de fondos durante la
pandemia hay que decir que es el
presidente de mario abdo benítez es el
presidente que más endeudó al país en la
historia reciente democrática y uno de
los cánticos presentes en casi todas las
manifestaciones que se están dando es
donde están los 1.600 millones de
dólares que el gobierno nos endeudó para
enfrentar esta crisis por el coi 19 ya
son 7 días de protestas
hay sectores ciudadanos que anuncian más
días aún y hoy en día el reclamo es que
el presidente abdo benítez y su
vicepresidente hugo velázquez salgan del
gobierno ya sea por juicio político o
por renuncia hay que decir que este
impeachment de este juicio político va
perdiendo fuerza a medida que pasan los
días ya que no hay votos necesarios en
el congreso bueno es otro país en donde
el tema político se une con el tema
sanitario y la salud y fernando la
vacunación
está avanzando muy lentamente de hecho
fue uno de los últimos países en
comenzar a vacunar en la región de
suramérica como está avanzando que dicen
las autoridades y cuál es el plan que
tienen estructurado allí
hasta ahora las vacunas contra el
coronavirus han llegado a cuentagotas a
paraguay son aproximadamente 4.500
trabajadores de la salud bloques fueron
inmunizados con las vacunas
spot 25 y astrazéneca
esto llegó al país a tener uno de los
peores registros de vacunación en todo
el continente de acuerdo con el plan del
gobierno el 30 por ciento de la
población será inmunizada en este 2021 y
en el 2022 llegaremos a un 2020 60 por
ciento sin embargo la espera
es dura para los trabajadores de blanco
que ven a médicos y enfermeras caer por
esta enfermedad e incluso ellos salieron
a protestar contra el gobierno exigiendo
que lleguen ya las vacunas por su parte
el presidente mario abdo benítez y sus
funcionarios sostienen que el mercado
paraguayo deja un muy chico para las
grandes farmacéuticas y esto es lo que
explica que no lleguen importantes lotes
al país fernando muchas gracias por este
reporte desde la ciudad de asunción la
capital de paraguay ahora demos un
vistazo al avance de la vacunación como
cierra el continente americano esta
semana en cuanto a la inmunización en el
mundo ya han sido aplicadas 335 como 44
millones de dosis mientras que en
américa del sur unas 20.11 millones de
dosis ya han sido inoculadas eeuu lidera
la vacunación en el continente americano
y también a nivel mundial con 98 punto
20 millones de dosis le siguen brasil
con 10 75 millones de dosis utilizadas
chile con 613 millones y cierra este top
méxico con 380 millones de dosis
y pese a que brasil es uno de los países
que lidera la vacunación a nivel del
continente americano ya lo veíamos con
las cifras el país parece comenzar a
desbordarse por la cantidad de casos que
está presentando esta semana en espacio
de solamente 24 horas murieron en
algunos días hasta 2000 brasileños la
tasa de contagio es muy alta y los
hospitales ya comienzan a verse
saturados estados como río grande do sul
y sao paulo tuvieron que adoptar
nuevamente medidas extraordinarias como
regresar por ejemplo el confinamiento
para poder hacer frente a esta crítica
situación varios organismos
internacionales han expresado su
preocupación indicaron que brasil se
está convirtiendo en un peligro para la
salud pública mundial vamos a conocer
más detalles con valeria sakon en
nuestra corresponsal del río de janeiro
valeria gracias como siempre un gusto
saludarla y de más detalles de la
situación general en brásil para
entender cuál es la magnitud de esta
emergencia que está viviendo el gigante
suramericano
brasil enfrenta el peor momento de la
pandemia con más de 2.200 muertos por
día y según los expertos falta poco para
que se registren 3.000 muertes diarias
además en un año de pandemia ya se han
superado los 270 mil muertos y se camina
hacia los 300.000 brasil en este momento
es el epicentro mundial del coronavirus
de hecho se calcula que el 10 por ciento
de todas las muertes que se producen en
el planeta se producen exactamente en
brasil en este momento podemos decir que
prácticamente la mayoría de los
hospitales públicos en los principales
estados de brasil están al borde del
colapso o colapsando y los mismos
expertos que hace dos meses dijeron que
brasil viviría una mega epidemia están
hablando ahora de un posible e incluso
colapso funerario en algunas ciudades de
momento se está intentando mantener la
situación con nuevas medidas de
restricción pero debo de decir que en un
año que llevo cubriendo la pandemia
nunca
hemos visto una situación tan difícil
siento de alguna valeria es muy
preocupante la situación allí y por
ejemplo en san pablo que es el estado
más poblado de este país es el polo
industrial de brasil allí están a punto
de colapsar los hospitales cuál es la
situación allí de los más detalles
champa hola es la ciudad más poblada de
brasil y también la más afectada por la
pandemia precisamente por esta razón
para evitar el colapso hospitalario el
gobernador yo autor ya ha ampliado las
medidas de restricción al movimiento de
los ciudadanos hasta el 30 de marzo
habrá un toque de queda entre las 8 de
la noche y las 5 de la mañana sólo
pueden funcionar los servicios
esenciales las iglesias permanecerán
cerradas
está prohibido ir a los parques y
también están prohibidos los eventos
deportivos son medidas a la desesperada
que están siendo imitadas para otras
ciudades como salvador de bahía y río de
janeiro hay que recordar que brasil
sigue después de un año sin una política
nacional de enfrentamiento la pandemia
nunca hubo un lock down de hecho hoy
mismo es jair bolsonaro el presidente de
brasil ha vuelto a criticar la
posibilidad de un lock down y ha vuelto
a recordar de nuevo la importancia de
que no pare la economía los gobernadores
y los alcaldes están solo hacer esta
lucha y no sé
ven a implementar un lock down de verdad
son medidas de media medio calado que
pueden paliar la situación pero los
expertos están de acuerdo solo lockdown
nacional de tres semanas a un mes puede
ayudar a revertir esa situación
dramática para la creación cuanto a la
ciudad de sao paulo pero aclaró que
también el estado es un pueblo que tiene
el mismo nombre tanto el estado como la
capital la situación es muy complicada
a esta hora esto mientras siguen
llegando las vacunas a este país
suramericano cómo está avanzando
entonces la vacunación en brasil está
siendo igual de lento como lo vimos las
semanas anteriores e incluso tuvieron
unos días en donde no pudieron vacunar
algunas personas porque no había dosis
disponibles
hasta la fecha brasil ha conseguido
vacunar a cerca de ocho millones de
personas que equivalen al 4 por ciento
de la población una población de 212
millones de personas que representa un
reto para el continente y para el mundo
brasil ha perdido mucho tiempo en la
compra de las vacunas sabemos que en
este momento se están suministrando la
china corona back y la vacuna de oxford
lastras erika y sabemos que los dos
laboratorios de brazil el instituto
butantán y la fundación oswaldo cruz
tienen capacidad de producir aquí en
brasil y están esperando para ello que
se realice la tan esperada transferencia
de tecnología mientras el gobierno ahora
se ha dado cuenta de que ha perdido
tiempo y está intentando la desesperada
a cerrar acuerdos la fire ofreció el año
pasado 70 millones de dosis y el
ministro de sanidad eduardo para suelo
dijo que no porque las condiciones en
sus propias palabras eran draconianas
ahora hay una vuelta atrás sin negocia
con la fire pero los tiempos de entrega
son lentos y todos los días el gobierno
tiene que cambiar
a sus planes de entrega hemos pasado en
pocos días de poder recibir 38 millones
de dosis a reducirlo a 23 o 25 hoy
también hemos sabido que el gobierno ha
comprado 10 millones de dosis de la
russa sputnik que sin embargo todavía no
ha sido aprobada por la agencia del
medicamento estamos en práctica en una
situación de 'impasse' donde en ciudades
como río de janeiro se han vuelto a
suspender por segunda vez la vacunación
y todos los expertos insisten en que la
vacunación junto a los down pueden
salvar el país del abismo es muy
complicada la situación en brasil es
valeria y no puedo dejar de preguntarle
por el regreso a la escena política del
expresidente luiz inácio lula da silva
que criticó al presidente bolsonaro
criticó la gestión de la pandemia y esto
generó todo tipo de efecto dentro de los
ciudadanos incluso ya hablan de un
llamado 'efecto lula en términos de
salud
en este escenario hay un nuevo factor el
factor lula esta semana el tribunal
supremo anuló todas las condenas por
corrupción contra el ex presidente luis
ignacio lula da silva que hizo factor
recuperó sus derechos políticos eso
quiere decir que va a poder ser
candidato en las elecciones de 2022 y
aunque todavía no haya dicho claramente
si va a ser candidato o no voy a ir
bolsonaro ya se ha dado por aludido esta
semana lula hizo su primer discurso
defendiendo la vacunación el uso de
mascarillas y en este mismo día vimos a
bolsonaro a sus ministros usando
mascarillas en un acto público algo que
el presidente negacionista no suele
hacer además su hijo el senador flavio
bolsonaro dijo en su cuenta de twitter
pocos minutos después del discurso de
lula que está a favor de la vacuna que
la vacuna va a crear empleos y que los
próximos meses brasil vacunará a
millones de personas
bolsonaro sabe que sin vacuna no puede
aspirar a la soñada reflexión
y en este momento a pesar de que todavía
se opone al lock down ha cambiado de
rumbo y ahora sí se ha vuelto un
defensor de la vacuna valeria muchas
gracias por este reporte de la compleja
situación que está viviendo brasil a
esta hora y pese a tener una campaña de
vacunación exitosa incluso envidiada por
muchos países chile retomar a algunas
medidas de restricción como el
confinamiento de algunas comunas en
santiago la capital y de algunas
ciudades del interior del país como
entender entonces estas dos caras de la
moneda vayamos a algunas de las razones
en el siguiente reportaje
sigan protegiendo se es el mensaje de
las autoridades chilenas que advierten
que a pesar de que alrededor del 25% de
la población ha recibido ya al menos una
dosis de la vacuna los ciudadanos no
deben bajar la guardia todavía en la
lucha contra el coronavirus hay que ser
muy prudente tener mucho cuidado de no
caer en el exitismo el gobierno ha
cometido errores del pasado de
compararse con otras argentinas le daba
lecciones hace un par de meses atrás de
que ellos tenían un mejor sistema
sanitario de la mejor 40 mediodía tiene
una mortalidad estado chileno comerá hoy
el error para ayudar a detener un mayor
aumento de nuevos casos chile ha
introducido medidas de cuarentena para
todos los viajeros procedentes de brasil
el país más afectado por la pandemia de
américa latina a partir de hoy día a las
5 de la mañana todos los viajeros que
llegaron que llegan desde brasil o que
han estado en brasil los últimos 14 días
deben irse a una residencia sanitaria
tanto chilenos como extranjeros en la
residencia sanitaria se les tomará una
pcr y aquellos personas que salen
negativo pueden continuar su cuarentena
en el aislamiento donde está decidido
por las personas las personas que salen
positiva en establecer deben continuar
su aislamiento en la residencia
sanitaria esto se produce cuando las
salas de la uci con pacientes de
coronavirus informaron de un promedio de
ocupación del 93 5% y algunas regiones
informaron de hasta un 18% más de casos
de kobin en los últimos días hasta el
jueves chile ha registrado más de 860
mil casos de kobe y más de 21 mil
muertos
vamos a profundizar en la situación de
chile patricia luna nuestra
corresponsable en santiago nos va a dar
más detalles hola patricia porque este
regreso algunas medidas como el
confinamiento particularmente en algunas
comunas de santiago la capital
hola santiago nos encontramos en el
centro de santiago en la plaza de armas
uno de los lugares más concurridos de la
ciudad que a partir del sábado amanecerá
completamente vacío como lo hará el
resto de la región metropolitana todas
las comunas de la región metropolitana
pasan a partir de este sábado a fase 2
es decir al segundo de los 5 pasos del
plan del gobierno paso a paso que
implica una cuarentena total durante el
fin de semana el gobierno endurece las
medidas cierra casinos y gimnasios
durante esta fase y también restringe
los horarios tanto de restaurantes como
de locales comerciales que tendrán que
cerrar sus puertas a las 8 de la tarde
esto ante el alza significativa de los
casos que se ha experimentado en las
últimas semanas el viernes se
registraban casi 6.000 contagios
positivos una de las cifras más altas
desde el momento más duro de la pandemia
que vivió en chile en junio julio de
2020 lo que preocupa a las autoridades
hay regiones del país como valparaíso en
el centro o la araucanía en el sur y bío
bío en el sur donde los casos de los
contagios positivos son los más altos de
toda la pandemia
y dos regiones también en el sur los
ríos y los lagos donde el número de
muertes por kobe de lo que va de año es
superior a todos los registrados donde
durante 2020 patricia y que dicen
entonces allí las autoridades porque
están disparados otra vez los casos de
contagio en el país
pues para muchos el alza de contagios
era una crónica de un suceso anunciado
el permiso de vacaciones que decidió
conceder el gobierno del que se han
concedido cuatro millones de permisos y
que permitió los viajes internacionales
para que los chilenos pudieran irse de
vacaciones aduciendo razones de salud
mental está en el origen de la polémica
para el colegio médico este permiso de
vacaciones es sin duda la causa del alza
de contagios una vez que todas las
personas que salieron ya han regresado a
la región metropolitana sin embargo el
ministro de salud mantiene que este no
es la razón del alza de contagios que se
debería a una política de comunicación
al que no fue lo suficientemente fuerte
para señalar que todavía existía en
riesgo si aquella y que ha llevado a que
las familias relajarán las medidas se
hubieran más reuniones familiares y
también más fiestas lo que ha desatado
un mayor número de contagios puesto que
en estos entornos es donde se produce el
mayor número de contagios señala el
ministro parís patricia pero claramente
este aumento de los casos contrasta con
el avance de la vacunación que es el
ejemplo para la región de américa
latina' qué novedades hay en cuanto al
plan cómo está avanzando cuáles
cierre la semana
el ritmo de vacunación sigue de forma
trepidante en chile este viernes el
presidente del gobierno sebastián piñera
y el ministro de salud de enrique parís
del retiro recibían la segunda dosis de
su vacuna según lo acordado en el
calendario de vacunación establecido por
el ministerio de salud puesto que ellos
tienen 71 y 72 años de edad
respectivamente son más de 46 millones
de chilenos los que ya han recibido una
primera dosis de la vacuna esto es más
del 24 por ciento de la población
chilena y más de 1,5 millones los que
han recibido dos dosis de la vacuna a
los que están vacunados completamente
esto es aproximadamente un 8% de la
población chilena si le alcanzó esta
semana el ritmo de vacunación más rápido
no sólo de américa latina sino también
de todo el mundo superando incluso a
israel según datos difundidos por el
ministerio de salud tomando como
referencia la revista científica online
world intacta
además el jueves se registró una
vacunación también récord en más de
400.000 personas aproximadamente
cuatrocientas mil personas en un solo
día lo que es vacunar un 2% de la
población chilena sin embargo el efecto
de la
no tardará todavía sentirse en las
cifras de contagios los expertos estiman
que será aproximadamente en mediados de
abril por esas cifras es que chile sigue
siendo el ejemplo para américa latina'
patricia muchas gracias por este informe
desde la ciudad de santiago de ustedes
muchas gracias por la sintonía nos vemos
la próxima semana otra vez en kobe 19 la
semana en américa
[Música]